des déchets en guise de cadeau de noël
un présent dont les douze ans se serait
bien passé dans la ville rose les
poubelles débordent et les déchets
jonchent le sol et pour cause depuis
plus d'un mois les éboueurs sont en
grève les collectes de déchets sont
limitées et rares sont les camions qui
quittent l'entrepôt une situation que
déplorent les riverains moi j'habite
dans une résidence les poubelles sont
pleines archi plein et est la même à
côté et tout oui c'est impensable
noël au milieu des arts dire c'est c'est
ça va être pire encore mais ce que à
noël ont fait énormément de déchet
imaginez que après les fêtes on aidé à
main et des amas d'ordures c'est presque
pire que la grève de la sncf pour le go
moi je comprends les éboueurs qui
défendent leurs intérêts face aux
mesures qui ont été pris par la
municipalité
maintenant bayonne il faudrait pas que
ça dure trop longtemps parce que bientôt
on pourra même plus marcher sur les
trottoirs vers la fin d'une grève rapide
rien n'est moins sûr depuis mardi les
éboueurs ou même amplifier le mouvement
pour les représentants de syndicats la
mobilisation se poursuivra tant que
leurs revendications n'auront pas été
prises en compte par les élus locaux
parmi elles le maintien de la pratique
dite du fini-parti
acté la semaine dernière elle
permettrait aux éboueurs de quitter le
travail dès la fin de la collecte
l'administration dans le cadre d'une loi
nationale dite des 1607 heures a décidé
de leur supprimer 10 jours de congé nous
en avions 35 donc de descendre à 25 mais
en plus et ça c'est pas dans la loi a
décidé de supprimer une pratique qui
n'est pas que toulousaine il s'appelait
le fini par qui l'administration a
décidé en fait le plus gros recul social
jamais encaissé par les éboueurs il est
normal que les éboueurs se rebelle pour
la métropole la décision de supprimer la
pratique du fini parti est légitime elle
aurait non seulement vocation à
améliorer la qualité du service public
mais veillera également à assurer la
sécurité des titulaires
le fini parti entraîne une véritable
course contre la montre les éboueurs
veulent terminer le plus tôt possible
conséquence ils ont tendance à mal
travaillé et prennent des risques
importants on note beaucoup trop
d'accidents du travail lors de la
collecte on ne veut plus accepter qu'ils
prennent autant de risques
depuis quelques semaines les et boire et
la collectivité négocié en vain aucune
réunion n'a pour le moment abouti à un
accord selon la métropole
l'amplification du mouvement de grève
lors des fêtes de fin d'année pourraient
avoir des effets néfastes pour les
négociations